- There's just so much
that was left unsaid.
- Sorry, man, breakups are hard.
- I just miss her.
- Has she called you back?
- She doesn't have opposable thumbs.
(slow music)
Hey, is it cool if I sit here?
There's like, no other spots anywhere.
- Yeah.
- [Brunette] Cool.
I'm on my last Canto.
- Are you kidding me?
- Wow, we're the only two people
in Los Angeles reading Dante.
- I'm Mary.
- [Brunette] Brittany.
- [Both] Nice to meet you.
- It's not funny, like it says it is.
(Mary laughs)
(wistful music)
Hi.
- [Mary] Oh, one sec.
Oh, by the way, this is my dog Laura.
- Oh, you have a dog.
- [Mary] Yeah.
- [Brittany] Cool.
We weren't always that into each other.
(hip music)
- Oh shit, I gotta get to work.
- Okay.
- [Mary] Hey, do you
mind watching Laura for a few hours?
She's super easy, just like, one walk.
- Okay.
- I'll see you later.
- [Brittany] Okay.
Bye, hon.
Who you voting for?
Seem like a Sanders.
You like go for a walk or ...
Guess we're gonna go for a walk.
But then, something changed.
(upbeat music)
We couldn't get enough of each other.
Yeah, sure, okay, bye.
My little Laura, I love
you so much. (mumbles)
You're a good girl, okay, bye.
(screams from TV)
(upbeat music)
- Brittany, what the fuck?
- What?
- What, is that Laura?
- Yeah, you like it?
But then, things got really hard.
- It's just, it's not working for me.
- I get it.
Laura, don't look at me like that.
- Get a grip, Brittany.
- Guess I'll go.
Oh, and you shit in my shoe?
Real mature, Laura, real fucking mature.
- Oh my god.
(sad music)
- But then came the drinking.
And the jealousy.
Who the fuck is she?
(sad music)
(screams from TV)
And that's what happened.
- Damn.
Well, you know what they say.
- To the world, you may be one person,
but to a doggie, you may be the world?
- No, time heals all wounds.
- Oh, no I haven't heard that one.
- It's a pretty common phrase.
- It's not one.
- Okay.
- Come on, baby, come on.
Hey.
- [Brittany] Oh.
- How are you?
- [Mary] Good to see you.
- Good to see you, too.
- [Mary] Yeah.
You've been well?
- I'm good.
- [Brittany] Awesome, cool.
- How are you?
- I'm good.
- Cool.
- [Brittany] Whoa.
Oh, hey Laura.
You look good.
I like this collar.
- It's a new one.
- [Brittany] I like that.
- Thanks.
- Well, good to see you.
- [Mary] Anyway, yeah.
- [Brittany] We should get
coffee or something soon.
- Totally awesome to see you.
- [Brittany] Cool, okay.
(wistful music)
Then I found out about an
offshore bank account she had.
- What?
- Not the girlfriend.
For her dog.
- There we go. (both laugh)